this morning we are going behind the
wheel of one of the newest cruisers in
the New York City Police Department the
department is among the first in the
country to get brand-new hybrid models
built specifically as police cars the
NYPD aims to have all 10,000 of its
vehicles become electric or hybrid
within the next five years Kris Van
Cleave took a test-drive and shows us
how blue goes green it sure sounds like
your typical police car and it drives
like one too but this Ford Fusion based
police responders sedan could be a go
changer it's the first true hybrid built
specifically to be a police car ford
estimates it will save more than
15-hundred gallons of fuel per car per
year
NYPD Deputy Commissioner Robert Martinez
hoping to phase out Wabo purely internal
combustion engine vehicle
over the next five years that will
reduce emissions and cut fuel costs
right now the NYPD spends about 15
million a year on gas for its 10,000
vehicles helping us is longtime NYPD
driving instructor detective Paul Cassie
OPA whipping around the department's
training track in Brooklyn
he showed us what this hybrid can do you
guys drive a car a little bit harder
than your average driver absolutely this
is not going to be the standard car that
mom and dad would pick up her grocery
getter mom and dad don't drive like this
at the grocery store I sure hope not
turning the black and white or in New
York City the blue and white Green has
taken a decade the NYPD started testing
retrofitted civilian hybrids in 2009
they improved fuel economy by two-thirds
over a gas-powered cruiser was that even
on Ford's radar that people would want a
hybrid police car no that was something
that kind
me thinking outside the box so
out-of-the-box no automaker was even
thinking about it until Martinez pushed
for it how long did it take you to sell
forward on building you a hybrid police
car it probably took two to three years
before I really thought they took a
series well all of our best learnings
come from our customers right Steven
Tyler is the marketing manager for
Ford's police business
he says the just introduced hybrid
Police Interceptor SUV is faster and
more fuel-efficient than the gas powered
model it's replacing all the tailpipe
emissions are reduced because the engine
is shutting off for extended periods of
time it's going to give you fewer oil
changes it's gonna give you a brake
changes because of regenerative braking
on the vehicle yeah fewer trips to the
pump with your officers the bulk of its
fuel savings come during the five hours
Ford estimates a police car spends
idling during a typical eight hour shift
the electric motor on the hybrid allows
the gas engine to turn off saving more
than 900 gallons a year per Cruiser
they're about thirty five hundred
dollars more than the gas powered option
a taxpayer is gonna hear that go is that
the best use of the money to spend more
on the vehicles than you could otherwise
get them before right so you spend more
upfront but just with fuel savings alone
you'll absorb that additional pay
a new feature on these new hybrids is a
perimeter alert as I get close to the
vehicle from behind the windows go up
the car automatically locks the doors
and will alert the officer someone's
coming the NYPD will get its first
hybrid SUVs this fall and plans to buy
hundreds of the hybrid responder sedan
we'll take it slow officer Marcos Rudin
is one of the first NYPD officers to
drive the new SUV we're cops skeptical a
hybrid could do everything they needed
it to do I'm gonna hear hybrid they
think Prius but this is not the case
with this car it definitely doesn't
Drive like a Prius definitely I was
always skeptical at first too until I
actually got my hands on it and I was
blown away but would he be blown away
with how I drove a police car now I
don't have an instructor brake that
sounds like a you problem so if I say
brake I mean brake it is fast for an SUV
corners very well
and yes the brakes work good unwind give
me gas even if I didn't always use them
flawlessly
I think the cones are still standing
it's a pass for CBS this morning
Saturday Kris Van Cleave Brooklyn remind
me not to ride with christen I'm jealous
no that is so smart it's amazing that
they had to convince Ford to do this no
well it's not just better fuel
efficiency they're now better performing
vehicles it's it's win-win right save
money down the road